MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
WELL WITH NO SENATE STIMULUS
AGREEMENT IN SIGHT, PRESIDENT
TRUMP TOOK MATTERS INTO HIS OWN
HANDS AND SIGNED FOUR EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS YESTERDAY.
THESE ACTIONS ARE DESIGNED TO
HELP STRUGGLING AMERICANS GET
BACK ON TRACK.
GOP HOUSE LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY
WAS ON THE FRONTLINES OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL NEGOTIATIONS.
HE JOINS ME NOW WITH MORE.
GOOD MORNING, CONGRESSMAN.
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT WAS THE PROBLEM?
WHY COULDN’T THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS COME TOGETHER ON
THIS MUCH-NEEDED STIMULUS?
>> WELL IT’S NOT SOMETHING
UNUSUAL.
REMEMBER, EVERY TIME WE’VE DONE
LEGISLATION, WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID, NANCY PELOSI HAS ALWAYS
HELD IT UP FOR HER OWN PERSONAL
WISH LIST.
REMEMBER WHEN WE DID THE CARES
ACT?
SHE HELD IT UP FOR MORE THAN A
WEEK WHEN THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WERE BEING UNEMPLOYED, BECAUSE
SHE WANTED MORE MONEY FOR THE
ARTS AND THE KENNEDY
CENTER.
WHEN THAT CRITICAL MONEY CAME
THROUGH FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT WENT TO THE EMPLOYEES,
REMEMBER THE  PPE AND WE WERE
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY, SHE HELD
IT UP AGAIN IN THAT FAMOUS VIDEO
IN FRONT OF HER REFRIGERATOR FOR
ICE CREAM THAT SHE DIDN’T
CARE, SO THOUSANDS OF MORE
PEOPLE WERE LAID OFF, AND NOW,
WHEN WE WERE SITTING HERE COMING
FORWARD WITH PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED
AGAIN, SHE HELD IT UP OVER THE
ISSUE OF POT AND SHE
BELIEVED POT WAS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE PAYCHECKS AND NOW WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID, HE REALLY
SHOWED HE WAS THE ONE PERSON IN
THE ROOM THAT PUT PEOPLE BEFORE
POLITICS.
HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT?
I’M GOING TO CONTINUE TO HELP
THE PEOPLE ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PLAY THESE GAMES I’M GOING TO
TAKE ACTION AND PUT AMERICA
FIRST INSTEAD OF YOUR OWN
PERSONAL AMBITIONS.
MARIA: SO I DON’T UNDERSTAND,
WHEN YOU SAY POT.
WHY DID THAT HOLD THINGS UP?
THAT’S WHAT HELD THINGS UP?
>> WELL THAT WAS ONE OF THE
MAJOR THINGS IF YOU WATCH IN
HER PRESS CONFERENCES THE
DEMOCRATS PASS $3 TRILLION
AND IN THEIR $3 TRILLION BILL IT
MENTIONED CANNABIS MORE THAN IT
MENTIONED RESEARCH OR  JOBS.
SHE WOULD SAY THAT YOU HAD TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT $15 AN HOUR
EXTRA IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT, WHEN
HER OWN MAJORITY LEADER SHED NO
THAT WASN’T A STICKING POINT AND
THAT SHOULD ACTUALLY BE LOWER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHAT DID HE DO?
HE MADE SURE THOSE WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED CONTINUE TO GET EXTRA
MONEY, FOUND COMMON GROUND,
WHERE NANCY PELOSI WOULD NOT.
SHE WOULD JUST TAKE THAT STRONG
POSITION THAT NOTHING CAN HAPPEN
UNLESS THE LIBERAL LIST OF ITEMS
SHE WANT AND ONE OF THOSE
HAPPENED TO BE POT.
MARIA: WOW, SO LET’S GO THROUGH
THE PRESIDENT’S EXECUTIVE ACTION
HERE.
IT’S CALLING FOR $400 A WEEK IN
SUPPLEMENTAL UNEMPLOYMENT AND
UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE THEY WERE
GETTING THE $600, AND THE ACTION
ALSO REQUIRES STATES TO PAY FOR
25% OF THE $400 WEEKLY
BENEFIT.
WHAT’S MOST IMPORTANT ABOUT
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS,
CONGRESSMAN, THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND?
WHAT ARE PEOPLE GOING TO FEEL?
>> WELL THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED RIGHT NOW WILL
CONTINUE TO GET THEIR STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT BUT THEY’LL GET
THAT EXTRA FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PAY
THEIR RENT, PAY THEIR HOUSING,
AND MOVE FORWARD, BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE JOBS NUMBERS, IT’S
TRUE THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
PRESIDENT, AT THE RIGHT TIME.
BRING THIS ECONOMY BACK UP.
THE MILLIONS OF MORE JOBS EVERY
SINGLE MONTH MOVING FORWARD.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED TO DO, GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
THE REAL CHALLENGE AND THE PAIN
HERE THAT THE DEMOCRATS COULD
NOT FIND COMMON GROUND IS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SMALL BUSINESSES
I THINK THEY NEED A LITTLE MORE
HELP WHEN IT COMES TO PPP, OR
WHAT ABOUT THOSE ITEMS WHEN WE
WANT TO TAKE THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
BACK FROM CHINA, THAT WE WANT TO
BRING THOSE BUSINESSES BACK TO
AMERICA.
WE COULD HAVE GOT TAX CUTS IN
THERE THAT PROVIDED THOSE
COMPANIES TO COME BACK TO
AMERICA, OR  WHAT ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT
WE COULD OPEN THEM SAFELY?
THOSE ARE ALL THE THINGS THAT
GOT HURT BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
WOULDN’T BE THERE.
THESE ARE THE ITEMS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER TO
DO, AS PRESIDENT, AND HE TOOK
THOSE ACTIONS SO THOSE WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED CONTINUE TO GET
FUNDING.
THAT NANCY PELOSI HAS HELD YOU
HOSTAGE, REMEMBER.
YES?
MARIA: HOW WILL VICE PRESIDENT
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
HANDLE ALL OF THIS?
WE ARE EXPECTING THAT HE WILL
ANNOUNCE HIS VP CANDIDATE IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
CERTAINLY BEFORE THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION WHICH IS IN A WEEK
AWAY.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING THERE?
>> WELL HE’S NARROWED THE FIELD
HE SAID IT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
WOMAN.
I BELIEVE HE BELIEVES IT BE A
WOMAN OF COLOR SO THE FIELD IS A
LITTLE NARROW AND ALL OF THEM
HAVE PLUSES AND MINUSES.
I MEAN IN THE LATEST DISCUSSIONS
HE TALKS ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS, A
NEW SENATOR FROM CALIFORNIA.
SHE HAS DIFFERENT PLUSES AND
MINUSES.
I’M NOT SURE SHE’LL ADD TO THE
TICKET.
REMEMBER WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT JOE
BIDEN.
I MEAN, SHE WENT AFTER HIM WITH
A VENGENCE WHEN IT CAME TO THE
CAMPAIGN, AND SHE NEVER
APOLOGIZED FOR IT.
THEN IF YOU LOOK AT SUSAN RICE
--
MARIA: WELL WHAT ABOUT SUSAN
RICE?
>> SUSAN RICE IS ONE THAT’S
VERY INTERESTING.
NEVER BEEN ELECTED BEFORE BUT
WHAT I REALLY THINK, WHAT WOULD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK?
SHE’S THE ARCHITECT OF THE IRAN
AGREEMENT WHERE WE GAVE HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO IRAN
AND WHAT DID THEY DO WITH IT?
THEY USED IT ON TERRORISTS
AROUND THE WORLD AROUND THE
GLOBE.
HER POLICIES ARE NOT SOMETHING
THAT AMERICA WOULD WANT, AND I
DON’T THINK SHE HAS A GOOD TRACK
RECORD WE WATCHED HER LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC NUMEROUS TIMES,
BUT THEN AGAIN, IF JOE BIDEN WAS
PRESIDENT DURING THIS VIRUS, WE
BE IN WORSE SHAPE.
REMEMBER HE WAS OPPOSED TO
STOPPING THOSE AIRLINES FROM
CHINA COMING TO AMERICA.
HE THOUGHT THAT WAS A BAD
DECISION.
IT TOOK HIM A MONTH BEFORE HE
EVER AGREED WITH IT.
MARIA: ALL RIGHT, I KNOW THAT
YOU’VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES AND PERHAPS
WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO DO GOING
INTO THE ELECTION.
REAL QUICK WE’RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME HERE BUT I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON GOOGLE.
ARE THEY GOING TO TRY TO CENSOR
CONSERVATIVE SPEECH
BEFORE THE ELECTION 85 DAYS AWAY
NOW?
>> NOT THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
TRY, THEY’RE ALREADY DOING IT.
YOU WATCH WHAT THEY DID IN 2016
WHEN THEY MET TOGETHER THE
SPECIAL PROGRAMS TRYING TO
BRING MORE PEOPLE OUT TO VOTE
FOR HILLARY BUT REMEMBER, THEY
HAVE 90% OF ALL SEARCHES ON THE
INTERNET GO THROUGH GOOGLE.
THEY DETERMINE WHAT YOU SEE.
THEY DETERMINE WHAT YOU
UNDERSTAND.
THEY CALLED THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAD NAZISM
IN OUR IDEALS.
THEY BELIEVE THIS WAS OKAY.
MARIA: I REMEMBER THAT.
>> THEY HAVE TAKEN LIKE THE
BRIGHT PART AND NOT ALLOWED
YOU TO SEE THEM SO THEY STOPPED
TRAFFIC FROM GOING TO IT.
THEY COULD TAKE CONTROL OF --
MARIA: YOU’RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
I NEVER SEE THAT.
THAT’S RIGHT, BUT FOR SOME